Alice:你还有币吗
Alice: Do you still have any tokens?
Lucia: 我还有几个
Lucia: I have a few left.
Lucia: 因为我刚才
Lucia: Because earlier...
Lucia: 我刚刚一直在那边
Lucia: I was over there the whole time.
Alice:多出来一个
Alice: Got an extra one.
Alice:那你玩吧
Alice: Then you play.
Lucia: 我刚刚一直在
Lucia: I was over there...
Lucia: 我刚刚那边打了一局那个什么射击
Lucia: I was playing a shooting game over there.
Lucia: 所以很长时间就过去了
Lucia: So quite some time passed.
Lucia: 但我只花掉了3个
Lucia: But I only used up three tokens.
Alice:哈哈哈挺好
Alice: Haha, that's good.
Lucia: 有哪个比较好抓的吗
Lucia: Is there any that's easier to win?
Alice:我觉得都
Alice: I think they all are...
Alice:我可能比较笨
Alice: Maybe I'm just not good at it.
Lucia: 还想再抓一次吗
Lucia: Want to try again?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:啊不想了
Alice: Nah, not really.
Lucia: 那我抓了
Lucia: Then I'll go for it.
Lucia: 我找一个
Lucia: I'll find one.
Lucia: 我也不知道哪个好抓
Lucia: I don't know which one is easy to win either.
Jake: 这个这这是不是很难抓呀
Jake: Is this one hard to win?
Tasha:  这种很难抓啊
Tasha: This kind is really hard to win.
Jake: 这个好大好大
Jake: This one is huge, huge.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 他爪子会松
Lucia: The claw gets loose.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 就抓上来之后
Lucia: So after it picks it up...
Alice:给你一点甜头
Alice: It gives you a little hope.
Alice:让你觉得离他近在咫尺
Alice: Makes you feel like you're really close.
Jake: 对开心一会
Jake: Yeah, happy for a moment.
Jake: 开心个5秒
Jake: Happy for like five seconds.
Lucia: 那边还有那个开车和射击的游戏
Lucia: There's also driving and shooting games over there.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我刚去玩了一局射击回来
Lucia: I just played a round of shooting.
Jake: 哈哈看看修硕打怎么样了
Jake: Haha, let's see how Shure is doing.
Lucia: 哎我去看看
Lucia: Hey, I'll go check.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Looks good.
Jake: 过弯了吗哥
Jake: Did you make the turn, bro?
Shure:  过了
Shure: Made it.
Jake: 过了过了
Jake: You did, you did.
Lucia: 厉害
Lucia: Impressive.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay!
Lucia: 这个也好长时间
Lucia: This has been going on for a long time.
Lucia: 我在这玩了好久了
Lucia: I've been playing here for a while now.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Lucia: 应该可以跳过耶
Lucia: I think we can skip this part.
Lucia: 我这的好像还有几个币
Lucia: I think I still have some coins.
Lucia: 其他其他的小伙伴们在哪
Lucia: Where are the others?
Jake: 还还有币吗
Jake: Do you still have coins?
Lucia: 好像还有几个
Lucia: Seems like I have a few left.
Jake: 还有还有几个呀
Jake: How many do you have left?
Lucia: 还有123 789
Lucia: There's 1, 2, 3, 789.
Jake: 好好多币
Jake: So many coins.
Lucia: 对刚好
Lucia: Yeah, just enough.
Jake: 可以我剩下
Jake: Alright, I have some left.
Jake: 剩下都只剩一个币了
Jake: I only have one coin left.
Jake: 只有你现在看你表演
Jake: It's all up to you now.
Lucia: 因为我玩的时间都很长啊
Lucia: Because I play for a long time each game.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 就我一局就可以玩三五分钟那种
Lucia: I can play for three to five minutes each round.
Jake: OK像这个3币就下去了
Jake: OK, like this, 3 coins just gone.
Lucia: 对我我抓了
Lucia: Yeah, I got it.
Jake: 1秒3币就对
Jake: 1 second, 3 coins, right.
Lucia: 我抓了两次
Lucia: I caught it twice.
Lucia: 我决定不抓了
Lucia: I decided to stop.
Lucia: 太费币了
Lucia: It's too wasteful.
Jake: OK对对对对
Jake: OK, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 你们还要玩点啥吗
Lucia: Do you guys want to play anything else?
Jake: 还还得学经济学
Jake: Still need to learn economics.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那当然了
Lucia: Of course.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 这些都是浮云
Jake: These are all just clouds.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Lucia: 对对这种这种就是成本太高了
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, this kind of thing is just too expensive.
Lucia: 收获太低
Lucia: The rewards are too low.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 你要玩点啥吗
Lucia: Do you want to play something?
Lucia: 还有9个
Lucia: There are 9 left.
Lucia: 咱三个人可以一人玩一局
Lucia: The three of us can each play a game.
Jake: 呵呵确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Jake: 在晃悠晃悠
Jake: Just wandering around.
Jake: 他们在开车
Jake: They are driving.
Lucia: 那边还有哦
Lucia: There's more over there.
Lucia: 哎我也去开
Lucia: Hey, I'll go drive too.
Lucia: 你们要开吗
Lucia: Do you want to drive?
Jake: 可以开
Jake: Sure, let's drive.
Lucia: 要开吗你开了吗
Lucia: Want to drive? Did you start?
Jake: 你这有9个币
Jake: You have 9 coins.
Lucia: 啊不开吗
Lucia: Ah, not driving?
Jake: 那能凑10 哎
Jake: We can gather 10, hey.
Lucia: 不开我就去玩跳舞机了
Lucia: If not driving, I'll go play the dancing machine.
Lucia: 啊不行这要带那个要带头盔
Lucia: Ah, no, you need to wear a helmet for this.
Lucia: 哈喽啊我也决定试试这个
Lucia: Hello, I also decided to try this.
Lucia: 还有谁要玩的吗
Lucia: Anyone else wants to play?
Lucia: 在我
Lucia: Over here.
Katrina:  只能玩一个人
Katrina: Only one person can play.
Shure:  还有几个币了
Shure: How many coins are left?
Lucia: 给我这还有我还可以再再开个车
Lucia: I have some here, I can drive again.
Lucia: 所以如果有人要玩的话可以再玩一局
Lucia: So, if anyone wants to play, we can go for another round.
Shure:  他可以再这个
Shure: He can go again.
Shure:  因为他赢了
Shure: Because he won.
Shure:  他是不需要再投币子的
Shure: He doesn't need to put in more coins.
Lucia: 哪个这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Shure:  所以如果想玩的话可以再来一次
Shure: So if you want to play, you can go again.
Shure:  杨老板要试试吗
Shure: Jake, want to try?
Jake: 再来一局
Jake: Another round.
Lucia: 那我跟你再来一局哈哈哈
Lucia: Then I'll join you for another round, haha.
Katrina:  那你俩玩
Katrina: You two play then.
Lucia: 所以啥意思
Lucia: So what does that mean?
Lucia: 是你那边不用投是吧
Lucia: You don't need to put in coins, right?
Lucia: 我这边投一下
Lucia: I'll put in one here.
Lucia: 啊行是咋整
Lucia: Ah okay, how do we do this?
Jake: 哦你无论如何都有一局
Jake: Oh, you always get a game anyway.
Lucia: 嗯然后呢
Lucia: Hmm, and then?
Shure:  啊不行不行不行
Shure: Ah no, no, no.
Lucia: 那你投呗
Lucia: Then you vote.
Lucia: 我因为我我已经投了咱俩要一块吗
Lucia: Because I already voted, should we do it together?
Lucia: 啊我这边投过了
Lucia: Ah, I've already voted here.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Lucia: 然后我按开始吗
Lucia: Then should I start?
Shure:  对你按开始
Shure: Yeah, go ahead and start.
Jake: 现在还剩几个呀不剩了
Jake: How many are left now? None left.
Shure:  正好对
Shure: Exactly, none.
Lucia: 重重
Lucia: Repeatedly.
Shure:  正好不剩
Shure: Exactly, none left.
Jake: 确实不剩了应该
Jake: Indeed, none left.
Lucia: 重新登录
Lucia: Re-login.
Shure:  你们你们
Shure: You guys, you guys.
Shure:  谁要再来一局
Shure: Who wants to play another round?
Shure:  来来试一试
Shure: Come on, try it.
Shure:  还有人要来一局吗
Shure: Anyone else want to play another round?
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh.
Lucia: 然后呢我现在我现在干嘛
Lucia: So, what should I do now?
Lucia: 他为啥要让我用微信
Lucia: Why does he want me to use WeChat?
Lucia: 开始
Lucia: Start.
Katrina:  不用微信
Katrina: No need for WeChat.
Katrina:  直接star star就行
Katrina: Just press star, star is fine.
Katrina:  什么手动挡啊
Katrina: What's with the manual transmission?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  手动挡我都忘记怎么开了
Katrina: I forgot how to drive manual.
Lucia: 没事难的就行了不重要
Lucia: It's fine, the hard part is not important.
Shure:  这辆怎么样可以
Shure: How about this car, is it okay?
Lucia: 可以就这样是吧
Lucia: It's fine like this, right?
Lucia: 自动吧
Lucia: Automatic then.
Lucia: 然后是什么
Lucia: And then what?
Shure:  啊不不不
Shure: Ah no, no.
Shure:  点这个啊
Shure: Click this.
Shure:  完了完了点错了
Shure: Done, clicked wrong.
Lucia: 咋这样吗
Lucia: Like this?
Shure:  啊你我靠
Shure: Ah, you... oh my.
Lucia: 应该
Lucia: Should be.
Shure:  能返回吗
Shure: Can you go back?
Shure:  完了返回不了了
Shure: Done, can't go back.
Shure:  完了他返回不了了
Shure: Oh no, he can't come back now.
Shure:  好吧那只能
Shure: Alright, then we can only...
Shure:  只能自己玩了
Shure: We can only play by ourselves.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Shure:  你点错了刚刚
Shure: You clicked the wrong thing just now.
Alice:这个还是第一第一视角啊
Alice: This is still the first-person view.
Lucia: 这还有吗
Lucia: Is there more of this?
Jake: 好你还有
Jake: Okay, you still have...
Jake: 一次还还可以吗
Jake: One more time, is that okay?
Lucia: 还可以吗
Lucia: Is that okay?
Lucia: 我我我不知道
Lucia: I-I-I don't know.
Jake: 是吧是啊
Jake: Right? Yeah.
Lucia: 是我就随便按一下
Lucia: I'll just press randomly.
Jake: 决决定吧
Jake: Make a decision.
Shure:  对这没没有用了
Shure: Yeah, this is useless.
Shure:  因为他得续费的
Shure: Because it needs to be renewed.
Lucia: 啊他后面就让我投币OK
Lucia: Ah, then it asks me to insert coins, okay.
Jake: 收获满满
Jake: We got a lot out of it.
Jake: 对还好还好有个东西证明我们来过
Jake: Yeah, fortunately, we have something to prove we were here.
Jake: 不然这一段可能就连不上
Jake: Otherwise, this part wouldn't connect.
Lucia: 还有谁要抓娃娃吗
Lucia: Anyone else want to catch dolls?
Lucia: 我刚拿了大概15个的样子还有仨
Lucia: I just got about 15, and there are three more.
Lucia: 对我刚对
Lucia: Yeah, I just...
Jake: 还有啊
Jake: There are more?
Lucia: 我刚拿了大概15个的样子
Lucia: I just got about 15.
Lucia: 居然还有仨
Lucia: There are still three more?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 还有还有三个
Jake: There are still three more.
Lucia: 可能因为我一直都在玩那些游戏
Lucia: Maybe because I spent a long time playing those games.
Lucia: 花的时间很久
Lucia: It took a long time.
Lucia: 所以他现在还有三个
Lucia: So there are still three more now.
Shure:  我们我们用钱生钱
Shure: We are making money with money.
Lucia: 这能推下来吗
Lucia: Can this be pushed down?
Jake: 呃那边还有一个保龄球一块钱
Jake: Uh, there's still a bowling ball over there for one dollar.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Jake: 玩了很久
Jake: Played for a long time.
Jake: 因为前面有个人投了两个币
Jake: Because someone put in two coins before.
Jake: 还剩一个就可以玩
Jake: Only one left to play.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 然后我们在钱生钱
Jake: Then we make money with money.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 我玩那个节奏大师也是玩了好长时间
Lucia: I played Rhythm Master for a long time too.
Tasha:  我也想玩节奏大师来着
Tasha: I also want to play Rhythm Master.
Lucia: 我也想玩节奏大师来着
Lucia: I also want to play Rhythm Master.
Lucia: 那要玩那个吗
Lucia: So, do you want to play it?
Tasha:  币不够吧
Tasha: We might not have enough coins.
Lucia: 呃他好像也是投三个
Lucia: Uh, it seems like you need to insert three coins.
Lucia: 然后然后那个
Lucia: Then, then...
Lucia: 反正投三个币可以玩我觉得
Lucia: Anyway, you can play it with three coins, I think.
Lucia: 将近将近6分钟左右
Lucia: For almost, almost six minutes or so.
Lucia: 所以我一直在玩那个
Lucia: So, I kept playing it.
Tasha:  我也想玩来着
Tasha: I also want to play it.
Lucia: 然后就导致我现在还有仨
Lucia: And now I still have three coins left.
Lucia: 我看看他他们说说哪个
Lucia: Let me see what they are saying.
Jake: 2/3
Lucia: 这个也行
Lucia: This one works too.
Lucia: 大家大家
Lucia: Everyone, everyone...
Lucia: 大家决定
Lucia: Everyone decides.
Shure: 对只需要投一个就可以
Shure: Yes, you only need to insert one coin.
Jake: 2-32-3呢李凯有个神仙有个菩萨
Jake: 2-3, 2-3, there is a god, a Bodhisattva.
Lucia: 这么神奇
Lucia: So amazing.
Shure:  因为有有一个人投了两个
Shure: Because someone inserted two coins.
Lucia: 哦那投投投
Lucia: Oh, then insert, insert, insert.
Jake: 有个菩萨之前
Jake: There was a Bodhisattva before.
Tasha:  这个刚刚是也投了俩
Tasha: This one also inserted two coins earlier.
Jake: 对这个也是2/3
Jake: Yes, this is also 2/3.
Jake: 这也是2/3
Jake: This is also 2/3.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 神奇
Lucia: Amazing.
Lucia: 谁先来
Lucia: Who goes first?
Jake: 来了
Jake: Here we go.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Lucia: 哇居然是现实和屏幕结合
Lucia: Wow, it's actually a combination of real and screen.
Jake: 哈哈哈是耶
Jake: Hahaha, it is.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Lucia: 哇厉害
Lucia: Wow, impressive.
Shure:  strike全雷打懂吗
Shure: Strike, a home run, you know?
Katrina:  火鸡大奖
Katrina: Turkey prize.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Shure:  练过
Shure: Trained for this.
Jake:练过
Jake: Practiced
Jake: 可以好下去吧
Jake: Can we continue?
Jake: 哈哈哈换下一个
Jake: Hahaha, next one
Shure:  下一位
Shure: Next up
Katrina:  加油
Katrina: Go for it
Lucia: 那我来好了
Lucia: Alright, I'll go
Lucia: 我没有这个
Lucia: I don't have this
Jake: 要拿要帮你拿东西吗
Jake: Do you need help with anything?
Lucia: 这怎么怎么啊
Lucia: How do I do this?
Lucia: 好可以的
Lucia: Okay, got it
Lucia: 谢谢嗯
Lucia: Thanks, um
Lucia: 帮我拿一下这个啊
Lucia: Can you hold this for me?
Lucia: 还有这个
Lucia: And this too
Lucia: 这怎么整
Lucia: How does this work?
Lucia: 就把它扔进去就行了吗
Lucia: Do I just throw it in?
Jake: 来
Jake: Here we go
Jake: 对就越中间越好
Jake: Yes, aim for the center
Jake: 你还有5秒钟
Jake: You have 5 seconds left
Lucia: 好像不是那么中间
Lucia: It doesn't seem centered
Jake: 挺好
Jake: It's fine
Jake: 那还你还有一次机会
Jake: You have another chance
Jake: 你可以往左边打一打
Jake: Try hitting it to the left
Lucia: 然后呢他会哎
Lucia: And then, will it... hey
Tasha:  球
Tasha: Ball
Jake: 球来了
Jake: Here comes the ball
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay
Tasha:  补中
Tasha: Hit it
Jake: 哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, good
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on
Lucia: 谢谢哎哪个是我谢谢
Lucia: Thanks, which one's mine? Thanks
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright
Jake: 稳稳健
Jake: Steady
Jake: 极其稳健
Jake: Very steady
Jake: 也有个火鸡
Jake: There's a turkey
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow
Shure:  strike
Shure: Strike
Jake: 上火鸡就一次
Jake: You only get one turkey
Jake: 全砸中就有个火鸡
Jake: Hit them all for a turkey
Lucia: 厉害
Lucia: Impressive
Jake: 哈哈没关系这左边右边都没有差别
Jake: Haha, it's fine, left or right doesn't matter
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow
Tasha:  啊我比你厉害哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I'm better than you, hahaha
Lucia: 82 哈哈
Lucia: 82, haha
Jake: 越歪分越高你知道不
Jake: The more crooked it is, the higher the score, you know?
Shure:  来下一位
Shure: Next one, please
Jake: 来来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on, come on
Katrina:  咿呀
Katrina: Eeyah
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no
Shure:  你这好随意啊
Shure: You're so casual with this
Jake: 哈哈手滑了
Jake: Haha, slipped my hand
Jake: 还有还有还有
Jake: More, more, more
Katrina:  太搞笑了
Katrina: This is so funny
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina:  是一个很随便的人
Katrina: Such a casual person
Katrina:  还有吗球来了
Katrina: Is there more? The ball is coming
Jake: 球球来了
Jake: The ball is coming
Jake: 球已经来了
Jake: The ball is already here
Katrina:  哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh
Shure:  送出去给他
Shure: Send it to him
Katrina:  OK这也可以
Katrina: OK, that works too
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure
Katrina:  补中
Katrina: Nailed it
Jake: 紫藤来
Jake: Violet, your turn
Lucia: 哎为什么会拿这把枪
Lucia: Hey, why did I get this gun?
Jake: 哎怎么这么多
Jake: Hey, why so many?
Lucia: 放着吧啊行
Lucia: Just leave it, okay
Shure:  好全中
Shure: Alright, all hit
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Nice
Katrina:  还有吗
Katrina: Any more?
Jake: 还有是吧
Jake: More, right?
Jake: 还有克星还有吧
Jake: More, there are still more, right?
Jake: 还有还有还有可心呢
Jake: More, more, where's Kexin?
Lucia: 还有吗哎又出来了
Lucia: Is there more? Hey, it's out again
Katrina:  还有哎
Katrina: There's more, hey
Katrina:  几个币啊
Katrina: How many coins?
Katrina:  玩这么久可以
Katrina: Playing this long is good
Jake: 呵一个一个一个
Jake: Haha, one, one, one
Lucia: 怎么回事啊哈哈哈
Lucia: What's going on, hahaha
Lucia: 他会让我再再扔一次吗
Lucia: Will he let me throw it again?
Tasha:  对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 那
Lucia: Then
Lucia: 那我就再把这一个打中呗
Lucia: Then I'll hit this one.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 稳稳健
Jake: Stay steady.
Katrina:  哇感觉可以
Katrina: Wow, it feels possible.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 他应该会还有一局
Lucia: He should have another round.
Lucia: 我怎么感觉
Lucia: I feel like
Tasha:  没有了啊
Tasha: No more.
Jake: 没了没了就结束了
Jake: No more, it's over.
Lucia: 啊哈哈棒棒拿去推币好了
Lucia: Haha, great, let's use the coins.
Jake: 还有两个币
Jake: We have two more coins.
Jake: 两个币就钱生钱嘛
Jake: Two coins can make more money.
Lucia: 是要推币吗
Lucia: Should we use the coins?
Jake: 对对对对钱生钱
Jake: Yes, yes, make more money.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 搞笑
Jake: Funny.
Lucia: 冰球
Lucia: Ice hockey.
Shure:  然后里面有一匹
Shure: And inside there's one
Shure:  有一辆700匹的
Shure: There's a 700 horsepower car.
Shure:  一个奥迪
Shure: An Audi.
Lucia: 要推币吗
Lucia: Should we use the coins?
Lucia: 推一个吧
Lucia: Let's use one.
Lucia: 找一个看哪个好推
Lucia: Find one that's easier to push.
Lucia: 这个这个卡住了这没开
Lucia: This one, this one is stuck, it's not open.
Lucia: 看别的吧
Lucia: Look at another one.
Jake: 哇
Jake: Wow.
Katrina:  这有啥技巧吗
Katrina: Is there any technique to this?
Jake: 天呐
Jake: Oh my god.
Lucia: 这个好像也没开吧
Lucia: This one doesn't seem to be open either.
Shure:  这这有人有人有人都
Shure: This, this one has, has people
Lucia: 嗯那种在动的应该才开着就这种
Lucia: Hmm, the ones that are moving should be open, like this one.
Lucia: 但这其实挺难的
Lucia: But this is actually quite hard.
Shure:  伸进去的时候对
Shure: When you insert it, yes.
Tasha:  伸进去时再放
Tasha: Insert it and then release.
Tasha:  放呀
Tasha: Release it.
Tasha:  放在哪了
Tasha: Where did you release it?
Lucia: 哦你按他才会释放好像
Lucia: Oh, it seems like you need to press it to release.
Tasha:  好石沉大海
Tasha: Okay, sinking like a stone.
Shure:  嗯再来一个我们
Shure: Hmm, let's try another one.
Jake: 这是蝴蝶效应
Jake: This is the butterfly effect.
Lucia: 就是是怎么放进去
Lucia: So, how do you put it in?
Jake: 在前1秒钟
Jake: In the first second.
Shure:  对对
Shure: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 然后按一下他才会掉下来
Lucia: Then press it, and it will drop down.
Lucia: 按微微按哈哈
Lucia: Press it, Tasha, press it, haha.
Shure:  okay放
Shure: Okay, release.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 好像叠住了哈哈
Lucia: It seems like they stacked up, haha.
Jake: 走吧哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, haha.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Lucia: 我记得小时候
Lucia: I remember when I was a kid.
Lucia: 这个推币机特别容易掉币
Lucia: These coin pushers used to drop coins easily.
Lucia: 现在好像都把它改造的越来越不容易
Lucia: Now it seems they've made them harder and harder to win.
Lucia: 赢了
Lucia: We won.
其他人：外面好 好清爽啊
Others: It's so refreshing outside.
Lucia: 嗯哈里面好吵
Lucia: Yeah, it's so noisy inside.
Shure:  哎杨老板呢
Shure: Hey, where's Jake?
Lucia: miniso
Lucia: Miniso.
Jake: 但是没有
Jake: But there's none.
Shure:  盒马盒马
Shure: Hema, Hema.
Alice:哎你有在西安玩比较多吗
Alice: Hey, have you traveled a lot in Xi'an?
Alice:常出门吗
Alice: Do you go out often?
Lucia: 很长但如果你说旅游景点的话
Lucia: Quite a bit, but if you're talking about tourist spots,
Lucia: 也是去过一些的
Lucia: I've been to some.
Lucia: 你是想去哪
Lucia: Where do you want to go?
Alice:那你觉得比较好玩的地方是哪里呢
Alice: So, where do you think is the most fun place?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 大雁塔
Lucia: The Big Wild Goose Pagoda.
Alice:哈哈哈还有呢
Alice: Haha, what else?
Lucia: 就因为西安的话
Lucia: Well, in Xi'an,
Lucia: 就他景点都是那些什么古迹什么的嘛
Lucia: the attractions are mostly historical sites.
Lucia: 如果你喜欢逛博物馆的话
Lucia: If you like museums,
Lucia: 可以去碑林博物馆还有陕历博
Lucia: you can visit the Forest of Stone Steles Museum, Shaanxi History Museum,
Lucia: 还有西安博物馆
Lucia: and Xi'an Museum.
Lucia: 但是陕历博好像这两年比较火
Lucia: But the Shaanxi History Museum has been very popular these past two years,
Lucia: 然后就特别难约票
Lucia: so it's particularly hard to get tickets.
Lucia: 就要提前几天开始约票才行
Lucia: You have to start booking tickets a few days in advance.
Lucia: 但是这几个
Lucia: But these...
Lucia: 碑林博物馆好像是要门票的
Lucia: The Stele Forest Museum seems to require tickets.
Lucia: 但是陕历博和西安博物馆都是免费的
Lucia: But Shaanxi History Museum and Xi'an Museum are free.
Alice:没事吧没事吧
Alice: Is it okay? Is it okay?
Lucia: 就只要预约就行
Lucia: You just need to make a reservation.
Lucia: 这就是那天那个的green party
Lucia: This is the green party from that day.
Jake: 挺好玩这些小孩
Jake: These kids are pretty fun.
Lucia: 为什么现在会有这么多室内的
Lucia: Why are there so many indoor...
Lucia: 这样的篮球场
Lucia: basketball courts now?
Lucia: 篮球不应该在室外打吗
Lucia: Isn't basketball supposed to be played outdoors?
Tasha:  可能帅吧
Tasha: Maybe because it's cool?
Lucia: 哈哈有道理哈哈
Lucia: Haha, makes sense, haha.
Jake: 对是一样
Jake: Yeah, it's the same.
Jake: 能室内就室内
Jake: If you can play indoors, why not?
Tasha:  现在干嘛去
Tasha: What are we doing now?
Jake: 也只能给小孩
Jake: Only for the kids.
Tasha:  怎么人不见了
Tasha: Why are people missing?
Alice:盒马哎人呢
Alice: Hema, hey, where is everyone?
Lucia: 人呢
Lucia: Where is everyone?
Jake: 剩下的人去哪了呢
Jake: Where did the rest go?
Lucia: 寻找我的iPhone
Lucia: Find My iPhone.
Jake: 好走走
Jake: Okay, let's go.
Jake: 晃悠晃悠
Jake: Let's wander around.
Jake: 嘿嘿公共switch
Jake: Haha, public Switch.
Alice:他们是不是去那个好特卖了
Alice: Did they go to that hot sale?
Alice:糖浆的味道
Alice: Smells like syrup.
Lucia: 啊好香
Lucia: Ah, it smells good.
Tasha:  哦果然他们已经开始买了
Tasha: Oh, they already started shopping.
Jake: 好玩吗有肉吗
Jake: Is it fun? Is there any meat?
Shure:  这这是一个
Shure: This is a...
Jake: 啥呀这都是
Jake: What is all this?
Lucia: 亚超市
Lucia: Asian supermarket.
Shure:  超级特价超市
Shure: Super discount supermarket.
Shure:  杨老板逛过吗
Shure: Have you been here, Jake?
Jake: 没有那
Jake: No, I haven't.
Tasha:  看才三块三
Tasha: Look, only 3.3 yuan.
Shure:  新加坡有有
Shure: Are there similar ones in Singapore?
Shure:  有这种的吗
Shure: Do they have this kind?
Jake: 3块3的牙刷好有
Jake: A toothbrush for 3.3 yuan, nice.
Jake: 好像没有一元
Jake: Seems like there's no one-yuan items.
Jake: 问到就是那种什么dollar
Jake: When you ask, it's always like "dollar" stuff.
Shure:  one dollar shop是吧
Shure: You mean the one dollar shop, right?
Jake:  one dollar那些
Jake: Yeah, those one dollar things.
Jake: 都有什么比较优秀的便宜的东西呢
Jake: What are some good and cheap things there?
Lucia: 不知道我也只逛过一次
Lucia: I don't know, I've only been there once.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 3块9的巴黎矿泉水早上
Jake: The 3.9 yuan Paris mineral water in the morning.
Shure:  挂面
Shure: Instant noodles.
Jake: 应该再整点这个对
Jake: We should get some more of this, right.
Lucia: 哦这个这个
Lucia: Oh, this one, this one.
Lucia: 在这里卖的还挺便宜的嘛
Lucia: It's quite cheap here, isn't it?
Lucia: 这在国国内有地方卖老贵
Lucia: It's really expensive in some places back home.
Jake: 卖老贵
Jake: Really expensive.
Shure:  确实 12块5呢
Shure: Yeah, it's 12.5 yuan.
Lucia: 呃卖老贵
Lucia: Yeah, really expensive.
Jake: 哦真的呀 12块5
Jake: Oh really? 12.5 yuan.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yep.
Shure:  星巴克那玻璃那个更贵巴黎水
Shure: That glass one from Starbucks is even more expensive, Paris water.
Lucia: oldly
Lucia: Oldly.
Jake: 啊这个些酒是不是也很便宜
Jake: Ah, are these wines also cheap?
Shure:  啊确实
Shure: Ah, definitely.
Jake: 整两瓶
Jake: Let's get two bottles.
Shure:  我靠这个香槟只要39块钱
Shure: Wow, this champagne is only 39 yuan.
Shure:  这个气泡酒
Shure: This sparkling wine.
Jake: 心动吗
Jake: Tempted?
Jake: 哎哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  real好便宜啊
Katrina: Really cheap.
Lucia: 而且这是Moscato
Lucia: And it's Moscato.
Shure:  就比较有名的是吗
Shure: It's quite famous, right?
Lucia: 对但是当
Lucia: Yeah, but of course.
Lucia: 当然也要看你
Lucia: Of course, you also have to see.
Lucia: 就是本身葡萄的质量怎么样
Lucia: The quality of the grapes themselves.
Lucia: 但是就是莫斯卡托应该是产地
Lucia: But Moscato, the place of origin should be good.
Lucia: 就这个地方应该不错了
Lucia: This place should be good.
Shure:  不是有效 2033年
Shure: It's valid until 2033.
Lucia: 没事酒酒酒
Lucia: No worries, wine, wine, wine.
Lucia: 好像没有什么特别特殊的
Lucia: Doesn't seem to have anything particularly special.
Shure:  蒋一蒋一撇
Shure: Take a look.
Jake: 选一品
Jake: Choose one.
Shure:  今天晚上蹦一下好吧
Shure: How about we have a party tonight?
Jake: 我们好啊
Jake: We're good with that.
Katrina:  就是可以搞点real不
Katrina: Can we do something real?
Jake: 今晚能蹦吗
Jake: Can we party tonight?
Shure:  可以也可以蹦
Shure: Yes, we can.
Shure:  因为冰箱里还有一瓶
Shure: Because there's still a bottle in the fridge.
Lucia: 冰箱还有一瓶
Lucia: There's still a bottle in the fridge.
Lucia: 我们那天买了一瓶起泡酒
Lucia: We bought a bottle of sparkling wine the other day.
Shure:  这个素材得给AI看一下吧
Shure: Should we show this footage to the AI?
Jake: 对 39块钱听个响挺好的
Jake: Yeah, 39 bucks for a sound, pretty good.
Lucia: 哈哈 39块钱听个响
Lucia: Haha, 39 bucks for a sound.
Jake: 对我我我买的那个10个USB的充电器
Jake: Yeah, I bought that 10 USB charger.
Jake: 也3030多块钱一个
Jake: It was like 30 something each.
Jake: 响也没有就是一点都都充不上
Jake: No sound, and it didn't charge at all.
Jake: 看起来挺牛逼
Jake: Looked pretty cool though.
Alice:气泡酒吗
Alice: Sparkling wine?
Jake: 这好歹能听个响
Jake: At least it made a sound.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 我跟我朋友第一回开起泡酒的时候
Lucia: When my friend and I first opened sparkling wine,
Lucia: 我们俩打开
Lucia: We opened it,
Lucia: 不知道接下来怎么处理
Lucia: And didn't know what to do next.
Lucia: 他就放在那
Lucia: Just left it there.
Lucia: 就过一会他嘣哈哈哈
Lucia: After a while, it popped, hahaha.
Jake: 哦延时崩
Jake: Oh, delayed pop.
Alice:听个响
Alice: Made a sound.
Jake: 延时听个响
Jake: Delayed sound.
Alice:虎邦辣椒酱
Alice: Hupang chili sauce.
Shure:  还有什么想买的吗Minasa
Shure: Anything else you want to buy, Minasa?
Jake: 还有啥好东西
Jake: Anything good left?
Shure:  你知道黄桃黄桃罐头吗
Shure: Do you know about yellow peach canned fruit?
Jake: 我知道治感冒的
Jake: I know it cures colds.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:哈哈哈啊
Alice: Hahaha, really?
Katrina:  买点小零食当那个
Katrina: Let's buy some snacks.
Lucia: 啊是真的可以治感冒吗
Lucia: Does it really cure colds?
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Shure:  真的
Shure: Really.
Shure:  在东北可以
Shure: In the northeast, it works.
Shure:  在别的地就不灵了
Shure: But not in other places.
Alice:不一定
Alice: Not necessarily.
Katrina:  买什么
Katrina: Buy what?
Lucia: 有这样的吗
Lucia: Is there such a thing?
Jake: 就跟拜佛似的也治感冒
Jake: It's like praying to Buddha can cure a cold.
Katrina:  哦哦黄桃罐头
Katrina: Oh oh, canned yellow peaches.
Shure:  就是这个东西
Shure: This is the thing.
Jake: 拜菩萨也治感冒对
Jake: Praying to Bodhisattva can also cure a cold, right.
Shure:  非非常的违心
Shure: It's extremely hypocritical.
Alice:拜妈祖
Alice: Pray to Mazu.
Alice:福建那管用
Alice: It works in Fujian.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  想买一包咪咪吃
Katrina: Want to buy a pack of Mimi to eat.
Katrina:  就当那个
Katrina: Just as a...
Katrina:  等早饭外卖
Katrina: Waiting for breakfast delivery.
Katrina:  的垫垫肚子那个
Katrina: To fill my stomach in the meantime.
Shure:  小零食可以
Shure: A small snack is fine.
Katrina:  对要是怕有的人胃不舒都行
Katrina: Yeah, if someone's stomach doesn't feel good, it's okay too.
Shure:  这不是野餐零食吗哈哈
Shure: Isn't this picnic food? Haha.
Tasha:  噔噔噔这个糖还挺好吃的
Tasha: Dun dun dun, this candy is quite tasty.
Alice:周冬雨
Alice: Zhou Dongyu.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Katrina: 一 块钱不在话下
Katrina: One dollar is nothing.
Alice:什么玩意
Alice: What is it?
Tasha:  不在话下薄荷糖
Tasha: It's nothing, just mint candy.
Tasha:  哦结你
Tasha: Oh, you paid.
Tasha:  你结过账了是吧
Tasha: You already paid, right?
Katrina:  我没有我买的是自己的东西
Katrina: No, I just bought my own stuff.
Katrina:  他们还没结呢
Katrina: They haven't paid yet.
Shure:  这样我们我们都给杨老板换
Shure: So, we all exchange it for Jake.
Shure:  换算成新币
Shure: Exchange it for new currency.
Katrina:  新加坡比
Katrina: Singapore dollars.
Alice:这样听起来就不心疼了哈哈
Alice: This way it doesn't hurt, haha.
Jake: 这个太离谱了吧 5毛星
Jake: This is too ridiculous, 50 cents.
Lucia: which one
Lucia: Which one?
Jake: 5毛钱的新币
Jake: 50 cents in new currency.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Shure:  3块9就5毛钱是吗
Shure: 3.9 dollars is 50 cents, right?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake: 是6毛钱吧
Jake: Is it 60 cents?
Jake: 是51:五点三吧现在得
Jake: Is it 5.3 now?
Shure:  你就除以5减3
Shure: Just divide by 5 and subtract 3.
Shure:  你大概除以5
Shure: Roughly divide by 5.
Shure:  然后再减去摸个0就对了
Shure: Then subtract some random 0, and that's it.
Jake: 对给我报新币吧
Jake: Yeah, just give me the new currency report.
Jake: 你这多少钱这
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  在7新币就
Shure: It's 7 dollars.
Jake: 七新币的酒
Jake: 7 dollars for the wine.
Jake: 这听这这也听
Jake: Listen to this, listen.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  听个响还能
Shure: Can you hear it?
Jake: 还来听个响
Jake: Let's listen some more.
Jake: 七新币的酒
Jake: 7 dollars for the wine.
Katrina:  OK了
Katrina: Okay.
Lucia: 好像也还行
Lucia: Seems alright.
Lucia: 奥迪和丽豆里面应该有不少这个价格
Lucia: There should be quite a few at this price in Aldi and Lidl.
Lucia: 你们那有奥迪和丽豆
Lucia: Do you have Aldi and Lidl there?
Jake: 我们不怎么买不太懂
Jake: We don't buy much, not too familiar.
Lucia: 怎么买OK
Lucia: How do you buy it then, okay.
Jake: 但是七新币听起来就很便宜
Jake: But 7 dollars sounds really cheap.
Alice:这个牌子小啤酒
Alice: This brand, small beer.
Shure:  这这多少
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  这不到1新币
Shure: It's less than 1 dollar.
Lucia: 媒体小铺
Lucia: Media shop.
Shure:  这这一袋那什么
Shure: This, this bag, what is it?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 呃body shop是一个英国牌子
Lucia: Uh, Body Shop is a British brand.
Alice:嗯这边破产了
Alice: Yeah, it's bankrupt here.
Shure:  然后他
Shure: Then he...
Shure:  他还拿了一个不到两两毛新币的
Shure: He also got something for less than 20 cents.
Alice:清仓
Alice: Clearance sale.
Shure:  一个薄荷糖
Shure: A mint candy.
Jake: 那随便吧哈哈哈
Jake: Well, whatever, hahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  哇以后就都给杨老板报新币
Shure: Wow, from now on, let's report everything to Jake in new currency.
Lucia: 那我买了瓶饮料可以吗
Lucia: Can I buy a drink then?
Lucia: 虽然我是自己喝
Lucia: Even though I'll drink it myself.
Lucia: 不过大概也就5毛星币吧
Lucia: But it's probably around 50 cents.
Tasha: 啊5毛新币
Tasha: Ah, 50 cents.
Lucia: 5毛新币
Lucia: 50 cents in new currency
Tasha:  新币的换算比例是
Tasha: The conversion rate of new currency is
Shure:  嗯除以5再抹个0
Shure: Hmm, divide by 5 and round off a zero
Tasha: 除以5再抹个0
Tasha: Divide by 5 and round off a zero
Shure:  对他说大概是5.3
Shure: Right, it's roughly 5.3
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag
Jake: 多少新币
Jake: How much in new currency?
Jake: 10块
Jake: 10 bucks
Tasha:  十个新币
Tasha: Ten new currency
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure:  52块4不到1新币
Shure: 52.4 bucks is less than 1 new currency
Tasha:  一个新币
Tasha: One new currency
Shure:  不行杨老板咱先别换算呵呵
Shure: No, Jake, let's not convert it for now, hehe
Jake: 来来来
Jake: Come on, come on
Jake: 怎么付啊
Jake: How do we pay?
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag
Lucia: 这放会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Won't it be a bit heavy if we put it here?
Katrina:  他提没关系
Katrina: It's fine, he can carry it
Lucia: 哦你提啊
Lucia: Oh, you're carrying it?
Lucia: 那那就放了
Lucia: Then just put it in
Lucia: 那我就不客气了啊哈哈
Lucia: Then I won't be polite, haha
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thank you
Shure:  留好小票了
Shure: Keep the receipt
Alice:你从这里回学校是得两个多小时两个半不到
Alice: It takes more than two hours, almost two and a half hours, to get back to school from here
其他人：对两个小时吧
Others: Yeah, about two hours
Katrina:  走吧盒马在哪呢
Katrina: Let's go, where's Hema?
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go
Jake: 来干正事吧
Jake: Let's get to business
Shure:  干正事吧
Shure: Let's get to business
其他人：还要回别墅拿东西
Others: We still need to go back to the villa to get things
Jake: 可以哎我看看还能录多久啊
Jake: Okay, let me see how much longer we can record
Alice:啊一个小时
Alice: Ah, one hour
Jake: 行那正好
Jake: Alright, that's perfect
Jake: 正事能干一小时吗
Jake: Can we do business for an hour?
Tasha:  可以
Tasha: Yes
Lucia: 这事是指买烤肉吗
Lucia: By business, do you mean buying barbecue?
Tasha:  玩具吧
Tasha: Probably toys
Jake: 买肉买肉可能用不着一小时
Jake: Buying meat might not take an hour
Katrina:  还要下去嘞
Katrina: We still need to go down there
Shure:  还要下去吗
Shure: Should we continue?
Jake: 买肉用不着一小时
Jake: Buying meat doesn't take an hour.
Jake: 再晃一晃
Jake: Let's wait a bit more.
Jake: 哈哈行吧行吧
Jake: Haha, okay, okay.
Lucia: 把肉围起来观察
Lucia: Surround the meat and observe.
Shure:  可是我们我们一会那个切肉什么的
Shure: But we need to cut the meat later.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  要要要
Shure: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 他当场切肉是吗
Jake: Does he cut the meat on the spot?
Shure:  不是我回去处理的时候
Shure: No, I handle it when I get back.
Lucia: 你当场切肉你当
Lucia: You cut the meat on the spot...
Jake: 你回去处理
Jake: You handle it when you get back.
Jake: 充完电了就重来了
Jake: Once it's charged, we'll start over.
Jake: 就重来了呀
Jake: We'll start over again.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 就不是这一波了
Jake: It's not this round anymore.
Tasha:  哦我已经看到他了
Tasha: Oh, I already see him.
Jake: 数据导完了
Jake: The data is uploaded.
Shure:  我也看到他了
Shure: I see him too.
Shure:  我看到了他的倒影
Shure: I see his reflection.
Jake: 谁啊哦
Jake: Who? Oh.
Shure:  在反转世界在镜花水月中
Shure: In the reversed world, in the illusion.
Shure:  我已经看到了他
Shure: I already see him.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  要不给他给大家喂个剪头素材
Shure: How about we give him some footage for everyone?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  我牺牲一下
Shure: I'll sacrifice a bit.
Alice:生瓜子的味道
Alice: The taste of raw sunflower seeds.
Alice:炒瓜子啊
Alice: Roasted sunflower seeds.
Shure:  啊哇好香啊
Shure: Ah, wow, it smells so good.
Alice:炒货
Alice: Roasted snacks.
Alice:哎呦炒货的味道好呛啊
Alice: Oh, the smell of roasted snacks is so strong.
Shure:  会跟人交流啊
Shure: Can communicate with people.
Shure:  有有点社恐吧
Shure: A bit socially anxious.
Lucia: 哎咱是不是要推个车
Lucia: Hey, should we push a cart?
Lucia: 哦哦他们推了
Lucia: Oh, they already pushed it.
Lucia: 突然发现忘记推迟
Lucia: Suddenly realized I forgot to delay.
Alice:他是不是还要买签啊
Alice: Does he still need to buy the stick?
其他人：签谁买了呗你不说
Others: Who bought the stick? Didn't you say...
Jake: 哦是那边有吧估计
Jake: Oh, it's probably over there.
Lucia: 可能有一次性的那种竹签对
Lucia: Maybe there are disposable bamboo skewers, right?
Alice:竹签吗
Alice: Bamboo skewers?
Lucia: 铁锹会不会比较贵一些
Lucia: Would an iron shovel be more expensive?
Alice:中间有没有直接带圈的
Alice: Is there one with a ring in the middle?
Jake: 签签签怎么整啊
Jake: Skewers, skewers, how to arrange them?
Shure:  这显得就很没用你知道吗
Shure: This just seems useless, you know?
Lucia: 嗯有道理
Lucia: Hmm, makes sense.
Jake: 那你干啥呀
Jake: Then what are you doing?
Lucia: 这有穿好的还有签
Lucia: There are already prepared ones and skewers.
Lucia: 所有的问题都解决了
Lucia: All the problems are solved.
Shure:  不咱们买点鸡翅
Shure: No, let's buy some chicken wings.
Shure:  我腌的鸡翅特别好吃
Shure: My marinated chicken wings are delicious.
Jake: 行整点整点
Jake: Okay, let's get some.
Katrina:  想要充分展示自己的能力
Katrina: Want to fully showcase my skills.
Shure:  要拿吗也拿点这个
Shure: Should we get some of this too?
Jake: 拿点拿点拿点
Jake: Get some, get some, get some.
Shure:  好吧就是咱们得保证一个饿不死的
Shure: Alright, we just need to ensure we won't starve.
Tasha:  羊肉
Tasha: Lamb.
Shure:  一个食食物
Shure: One food item.
Shure:  然后在在死之上
Shure: And then beyond survival.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Lucia: 啊这是羊排吗
Lucia: Ah, are these lamb chops?
Shure:  我靠羊排
Shure: Wow, lamb chops.
Jake: 啥呀
Jake: What?
Shure:  然后可以
Shure: Then we can...
Tasha:  一个新币
Tasha: One new coin.
Tasha:  加起来一共两个新币
Tasha: Together it's two new coins.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice:10
Alice: 10.
Alice:10点多
Alice: 10 something.
Jake: 买买两个新币在新加坡就有半根串
Jake: Buy two new coins in Singapore, it's only half a skewer.
Shure:  然后就
Shure: And then just...
Katrina:  真的吗这么贵
Katrina: Really, that expensive?
Jake: 哈哈真的是的
Jake: Haha, it really is.
Lucia: 10新币
Lucia: 10 new coins?
Shure:  五十九十新币
Shure: Fifty, ninety new coins.
Shure:  你怎么算的哈哈
Shure: How did you calculate that, haha?
Lucia: 算成50:1了
Lucia: Calculated as 50:1.
Tasha:  这5:1吗 5:1
Tasha: Is it 5:1? 5:1.
Jake: 5对5.3
Jake: 5 to 5.3.
Lucia: 哈 5比5点多
Lucia: Ha, it's a little over 5.5.
Jake: 对大概一根串
Jake: Yeah, about one skewer.
Jake: 就牛肉串
Jake: Just beef skewers.
Lucia: 为了方便可以先按5算
Lucia: For convenience, we can just count it as 5.
Jake: 这种牛肉串
Jake: These kinds of beef skewers.
Jake: 大概就是哎这种串
Jake: It's roughly, hey, these kinds of skewers.
Jake: 一一新币一个哦
Jake: One dollar per skewer.
Jake: 一新币一串
Jake: 对一新币一串
Jake: Yeah, one dollar per skewer.
Jake: 位置好一点就两新币一串
Jake: If the location is better, it's two dollars per skewer.
Shure:  不行我这不不需要不需要
Shure: No, I don't need that, we don't need that.
Shure:  咱们不用这些
Shure: We're not using those.
Shure:  这这些肯定不好吃
Shure: Those definitely don't taste good.
Katrina:  你有自己独家配方来腌吗
Katrina: Do you have your own secret marinade recipe?
Katrina:  还是怎么
Katrina: Or what?
Shure:  是的祖传十八辈了已经
Shure: Yeah, it's been passed down for 18 generations.
Lucia: 瓜子大礼包
Lucia: Big pack of sunflower seeds.
Jake: 哎肉买完了吗
Jake: Hey, did you finish buying the meat?
Lucia: 内含三种口味
Lucia: It has three flavors inside.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
其他人：怎么还有藤椒的瓜子
Others: How come there are Sichuan peppercorn sunflower seeds?
Lucia: 我也想知道
Lucia: I want to know too.
其他人：好奇怪啊
Others: So strange.
Lucia: 世界好癫
Lucia: The world is so crazy.
Katrina:  什么东西啊
Katrina: What is that?
Lucia: 藤椒味的瓜子
Lucia: Sichuan peppercorn flavored sunflower seeds.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  之前有藤椒冰淇淋呢
Katrina: There was Sichuan peppercorn ice cream before.
Lucia: 啊真的还有藤椒冰淇淋啊
Lucia: Really? There was Sichuan peppercorn ice cream?
Katrina:  麦当劳这边出在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's had it as a Sichuan exclusive.
Lucia: 麦当劳是有什
Lucia: McDonald's has what?
Lucia: 麦当劳你有什么心事吗
Lucia: McDonald's, do you have something on your mind?
Jake: 藤椒瓜藤椒冰淇淋
Jake: Sichuan peppercorn ice cream.
Jake: 藤椒瓜子
Jake: Sichuan peppercorn sunflower seeds.
Katrina:  之前麦当劳出过在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's had it before as a Sichuan exclusive.
Jake: 藤椒冰淇淋我靠
Jake: Sichuan peppercorn ice cream, damn.
Katrina:  就是还浇那个辣子油
Katrina: And they even poured chili oil on it.
Katrina:  crazy
Katrina: Crazy.
Shure:  一斤多可以羊排
Shure: Over a pound, it could be lamb chops.
其他人：没事没事
Others: No worries, no worries.
Jake: 来放进去放进去
Jake: Come on, put it in, put it in.
Shure:  来我需要洋葱调料
Shure: Hey, I need the onion seasoning.
Jake: 串那个竹签怎么整
Jake: How do we skewer the bamboo stick?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 竹签竹签儿
Jake: The bamboo stick, the bamboo stick.
Katrina:  他就直接烤肉了
Katrina: He's just grilling the meat directly.
Shure:  直接用这个
Shure: Just use this.
Shure:  然后不穿
Shure: And don't skewer it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  咱们就烤片
Shure: We'll just grill slices.
Shure:  然后腌好
Shure: Then marinate.
Shure:  然后烤片可以吧
Shure: Then grill the slices, okay?
Jake: 行行行不要签了
Jake: Okay, okay, no need for skewers.
Alice:有那个夹子吗 翻面的
Alice: Is there a tong for flipping?
Shure:  啊对好问题
Shure: Ah, good question.
Shure:  咱们再补个夹子
Shure: Let's get a tong too.
Katrina:  对刷子跟油
Katrina: Right, and a brush with oil.
Alice:沙子跟油
Alice: Sand and oil.
Shure:  好问题啊
Shure: Good question.
Shure:  油有刷子刷子也有刷刷子
Shure: We've got oil, and a brush, and another brush.
Alice:孜然
Alice: Cumin.
其他人：应该有吧他那个烧烤套装
Others: It should be in the BBQ set.
Shure:  哎那谁呢
Shure: Hey, where is it?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 就是公寓
Jake: It's in the apartment.
Jake: 在别墅里面有是吧
Jake: There's one in the villa, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
其他人：应该有
Others: It should be.
Jake: 别说有那夹子哈
Jake: Don't say there's no tong.
Shure:  啊OK
Shure: Ah, okay.
Alice:吃筷子也能
Alice: Chopsticks can work too.
Shure:  我为什么要拎着他呀我靠
Shure: Why am I carrying it? Oh my gosh.
Shure:  还想起来
Shure: I just remembered.
Shure:  我还傻傻地拎着他
Shure: I was dumbly carrying it.
Shure:  这时候就应该向他问一个问题
Shure: I should have asked him a question then.
Shure:  为什么我有一个车而不放进去
Shure: Why do I have a car and not put it in?
Jake: 他花了多长时间意识到这个问题
Jake: How long did it take him to realize this?
Shure:  对他花了
Shure: Yeah, it took him...
Shure:  我花了多久意识到这个问题
Shure: How long did it take me to realize this?
Lucia: 啊这是什么
Lucia: Ah, what is this?
其他人：这个老鼠头还蛮可爱的
Others: This mouse head is actually quite cute.
Jake: 啊啊确实很贵啊
Jake: Ah, it really is expensive.
Jake: 75
Jake: 75.
Lucia: 十十五新币
Lucia: Ten, fifteen Singapore dollars.
Jake: 初代
Jake: The first generation.
Jake: 也也挺贵的
Jake: It's also quite expensive.
Shure:  呀
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  没有看到鸡翅吗
Shure: Didn't you see the chicken wings?
Lucia: 我每次刚出去的时候就会
Lucia: Every time I just go out...
Lucia: 每次看到东西都会转成人民币对
Lucia: Every time I see something, I convert it to RMB.
Jake: 哦转对转回来然后回国了
Jake: Oh, you convert and then go back home.
Lucia: 然后回国就问
Lucia: And then when I go back, I ask.
Jake: 对对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 所以我上次在上海的时候惊讶的发现
Lucia: So last time when I was in Shanghai, I was surprised to find...
Lucia: 上海东西竟然没比英国便宜多少
Lucia: Things in Shanghai aren't much cheaper than in the UK.
Jake: 哦是啊是吧
Jake: Oh, really, right?
Lucia: 好多东西嗯
Lucia: Many things, yeah.
Lucia: 也可能我老去立冬和奥迪a
Lucia: Maybe I often go to Lidong and Audi A.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 这段删掉
Lucia: Edit this part out.
Lucia: 听起来我生活的好好悲惨
Lucia: It makes my life sound so miserable.
Jake: 7块九两瓶
Jake: 7.9 for two bottles.
Lucia: 要喝吗
Lucia: Want to drink?
Jake: 海参这
Jake: This sea cucumber.
Jake: 149
Jake: 149.
Lucia: 149的是加拿大雪蟹
Lucia: The 149 one is Canadian snow crab.
Lucia: 海参是39块9100克哎
Lucia: Sea cucumber is 39.9 for 100 grams.
Lucia: 如果是冻鲜的那还挺便宜的嘞
Lucia: If it's frozen fresh, then it's quite cheap.
Lucia: 暗示的眼神
Lucia: Giving a hinting look.
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 我开玩笑的
Lucia: I'm just kidding.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake: 我在想这
Jake: I was thinking...
Jake: 东西怎么吃
Jake: How to eat this.
Jake: 早上可以吃
Jake: You can eat it in the morning.
Jake: 但是不知道怎么吃
Jake: But I don't know how to eat it.
Lucia: 一般就是煲汤喝吧
Lucia: Usually, you just make soup with it.
Jake: 世界
Jake: World
Lucia: 不过我觉得
Lucia: But I think
Lucia: 咱们肯定也没有多余的时间
Lucia: We definitely don't have much extra time
Jake: 啊对
Jake: Ah, right
Lucia: 很用心的去煲它
Lucia: To really take the time to cook it
Jake: 对煲汤
Jake: Yeah, to make soup
Lucia: 因为那种就是干的在泡发的海参
Lucia: Because those dried sea cucumbers that need to be rehydrated
Jake: 推过去
Jake: Push it over
Jake: 哈哈哈没有因为不够了
Jake: Hahaha, no, because it's not enough
Lucia: 我来推没事哈哈哈
Lucia: I'll push it, no problem, haha
Tasha:  猜猜为什么要买鸡蛋
Tasha: Guess why we need to buy eggs
Tasha:  对因为鸡蛋消耗比例太大啊
Tasha: Right, because we use up eggs really fast
Lucia: 哦那天
Lucia: Oh, that day
Jake: 今天还要做甜点
Jake: We still need to make dessert today
Jake: 你要多少
Jake: How many do you need?
Tasha:  啊鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Ah, eggs?
Jake: 啊你要
Jake: Ah, how many do you need?
Tasha:  一次甜品可能要10个鸡蛋吧
Tasha: Maybe around 10 eggs for a dessert
Jake: 你还缺多少啊
Jake: How many more do you need?
Jake: 好嘞你还缺什么吗
Jake: Okay, do you need anything else?
Jake: 今儿
Jake: Today
Tasha:  我不缺什么
Tasha: I don't need anything
Lucia: 今天这个应该够
Lucia: This should be enough for today
Jake: 今天做什么呀
Jake: What are we making today?
Lucia: 哪怕在就是意外消耗应该也够了
Lucia: Even with unexpected uses, it should be enough
Tasha:  今天做什么
Tasha: What are we making today?
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha:  都可以啊
Tasha: Anything is fine
Jake: oh好
Jake: Oh, okay
Tasha:  你想吃什么
Tasha: What do you want to eat?
Jake: 那就选一个
Jake: Then just pick one
Jake: 在众多图片里边选一个
Jake: Pick one from all these pictures
Tasha:  买点sweet drink吧
Tasha: Let's buy some sweet drinks
Lucia: 可以呀我都可以
Lucia: Sure, I'm good with that
Lucia: 看你想喝啥
Lucia: Whatever you want to drink
Lucia: 好累呀
Lucia: So tired
Tasha:  我也是脚都走痛了
Tasha: Me too, my feet hurt from walking
Lucia: 我我的本体是一只树懒
Lucia: My true form is a sloth
Tasha:  他更像
Tasha: He looks more like it
Jake: 动作太快了
Jake: Moving too fast
Jake: 我怎么就树懒了呀
Jake: Why am I called a sloth?
Lucia: 没有他是卡皮吧啦
Lucia: No, he's a capybara.
Jake: 那是啥
Jake: What's that?
Lucia: 情绪稳定啊
Lucia: It's very calm.
Lucia: 你不知道这个梗吗
Lucia: You don't know this meme?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No idea.
Lucia: 这是水豚
Lucia: It's a capybara.
Lucia: 是一种很可爱的动物
Lucia: It's a really cute animal.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 然后他就是情绪特别稳定
Lucia: And it's super calm.
Lucia: 就是即使电脑的电线断了
Lucia: Even if the computer's cable breaks,
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 他也能就是情绪稳定的按住
Lucia: It stays calm until the problem is solved.
Lucia: 直到把问题解决为止
Lucia: Until the problem is solved.
Tasha:  又买土豆
Tasha: Buying potatoes again?
其他人：不买土豆啊
Others: No more potatoes.
Tasha:  买
Tasha: Buy them.
Shure:  可以烤点
Shure: We can bake some.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:  烤点
Tasha: Bake some.
Shure:  想想啊咱们是7个人
Shure: Think about it, we are 7 people.
Jake: 这样你吃不了
Jake: You can't finish it.
其他人：我吃不了待会就走了
Others: I can't finish it, I'll leave soon.
Shure:  是7个人吃是吧
Shure: Seven people eating, right?
Tasha:  那要不要买那个烤料
Tasha: Should we buy some barbecue seasoning?
Tasha:  烤烧烤料
Tasha: Barbecue seasoning.
Shure:  是的我先算一下肉要多些
Shure: Yes, let me calculate the meat quantity first.
Shure:  这么多鸡蛋
Shure: So many eggs.
Lucia: 这薇薇要做甜点要用
Lucia: Those are for Tasha's dessert.
Shure:  啊那一会借我两个
Shure: Ah, can I borrow two later?
Tasha:  不借哈哈哈哈
Tasha: No borrowing, haha.
Lucia: 哦你要糊那个啥是吗
Lucia: Oh, you need them for coating, right?
Shure:  要要腌的话会
Tasha:  要腌
Tasha: For marinating.
Tasha:  东西要用嗯
Tasha: We need them for marinating.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 我以为要往上面裹汁嘞
Lucia: I thought you were coating them.
Tasha:  洋葱在这里就有
Tasha: The onions are here.
Alice:但是他你要不
Alice: But if you don't want to...
Jake: 哦真远
Jake: Oh, that's really far.
Alice:买那个洋葱吧
Alice: Buy that onion.
Shure:  我要紫皮洋葱
Shure: I want the purple-skinned onion.
Shure:  紫皮洋葱
Shure: Purple-skinned onion.
Jake: 这个很紫啊
Jake: This one is really purple.
Lucia: 紫的这种的呗
Lucia: The purple kind, right?
Jake: 这边啊
Jake: Over here.
Alice:这个有机的
Alice: This one is organic.
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much is the organic one?
Tasha:  没关系我们就吃贵的
Tasha: It's okay, we can just get the expensive one.
Lucia: 要大的还是小的
Lucia: Do you want a big one or a small one?
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much is the organic one?
Tasha:  我觉得要小的比较
Tasha: I think the small ones are better.
Tasha:  呃要三个小的比较好
Tasha: Uh, three small ones would be better.
Tasha:  这样子的话就不会浪费
Tasha: This way, we won't waste any.
Shure:  100克五块九
Shure: 100 grams for 5.9.
Lucia: 400克5块9 这个是那个类
Lucia: 400 grams for 5.9. This is that kind.
Jake: 这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Lucia: 如果我没看错
Lucia: If I read it correctly.
Jake: 这多少钱半新币
Jake: How much is this in half a new currency?
Jake: 没差别
Jake: No difference.
Jake: 那没差别
Jake: There's no difference.
Jake: 有机
Jake: Organic.
Tasha:  没差别
Tasha: No difference.
Jake: 哈哈啊就差一块钱
Jake: Haha, it's just one dollar difference.
Shure:  啊但是这个比那个轻 100克
Shure: Ah, but this one is lighter, 100 grams.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  够了这些
Shure: That's enough.
Shure:  然后肉的话一斤一斤半
Shure: And for the meat, one to one and a half pounds.
Alice:需要土豆什么吗
Alice: Do we need potatoes or something?
Alice:土豆生菜
Alice: Potatoes, lettuce.
Shure:  土豆拿了
Shure: We got the potatoes.
Shure:  然后底下那些串
Shure: And those skewers at the bottom.
Alice:生菜
Alice: Lettuce.
Shure:  然后也也有肉是不
Shure: And also the meat, right?
Shure:  这是多少斤
Shure: How many pounds is this?
Alice:生菜需要吗
Alice: Do we need lettuce?
Shure:  需要拿点生菜
Shure: Yes, we need some lettuce.
Alice:生菜在那呢
Alice: The lettuce is over there.
Lucia: 要推过去吗
Lucia: Should we push it over?
Lucia: 还是什么情况
Lucia: Or what's going on?
其他人：现在可心在拿生菜
Others: Now Kexin is getting the lettuce.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Jake: 我们回去之后
Jake: When we get back...
Jake: 呃哪一个小时用来给我传数据了
Jake: Uh, which hour are you using to send me the data?
Shure:  立即传
Shure: Sending it now.
Lucia: 刚回去的那个小时吧
Lucia: The hour right after we got back?
Jake: 立即传啊
Jake: Send it now.
其他人：对然后再开始
Others: Yeah, then we can start.
Shure:  对因为我们要处理这些的
Shure: Yeah, because we need to handle these.
Shure:  就也要也要拍一下了是吧
Shure: We need to take a picture too, right?
Jake: OK那对对是的
Jake: OK, yes, exactly.
Jake: 所以回去之后先放冰箱就给我传是吗
Jake: So after we get back, put it in the fridge first, then send it to me, right?
Jake: 要放冰箱吗
Jake: Does it need to go in the fridge?
Shure:  对也其实也
Shure: Yeah, actually, also...
Alice:要的要的
Lucia: 放冰箱要拍吗
Jake: 要拍放一下吧
Lucia: 那就放啊
Alice:冷藏一下
Jake: 放下等着然后开始切是吧
其他人：你们几个吃差不多够了
Shure:  咱们7个人吧不是
其他人：有主食吗
Shure:  没有主食
其他人：那就不吃主食
Shure:  对不吃主食
Lucia: 主食土土土豆
其他人：烤面包片也可以
Jake: 有有土豆
Lucia: 那土豆也算是一种主食
Lucia: 因为主要主要成分是淀粉对吧
Lucia: Because the main ingredient is starch, right?
Alice:土豆三个够吗
Alice: Are three potatoes enough?
其他人：面包片要烤吗
Others: Do we need to toast the bread slices?
Lucia: 强词夺理
Lucia: That's just sophistry.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈是主食
Jake: Hahaha, it’s a staple food.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈对
Lucia: Hahahahaha, right.
Jake: 确实是主食
Jake: It really is a staple food.
Jake: 土豆泥对吧
Jake: Mashed potatoes, right?
其他人：对我吃烧烤就想吃面包片
Others: Yeah, when I have BBQ, I always want some bread.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 面包片做早饭是吧
Jake: Toast for breakfast, right?
Jake: 明明天做个早饭吧
Jake: Let's make breakfast tomorrow.
其他人：烤烤着好吃
Others: Toasted is tasty.
Jake: 啊好好
Jake: Ah, okay.
Jake: 哈哈哈现在点菜
Jake: Hahaha, now let's order food.
Jake: 其实点菜还要吃什么烧烤
Jake: Actually, what else do we need to order for the BBQ?
Katrina:  有水果吗
Katrina: Do we have any fruit?
Katrina:  我们水果吃完了好像都
Katrina: It seems like we've eaten all the fruit.
Alice:没有
Alice: No, we don't.
Lucia: 那我们要不买买点什么水果好啊
Lucia: Should we buy some more fruit?
Katrina:  买点好剥的
Katrina: Get some easy-to-peel ones.
Katrina:  橘子还有那个阳光玫瑰那个
Katrina: Oranges and those Sunshine grapes.
Lucia: 哎我们之前是买了一颗蓝莓
Lucia: Hey, we bought some blueberries earlier.
Lucia: 还在冰箱里
Lucia: They're still in the fridge.
Lucia: 今天今天
Lucia: Today, today...
Lucia: 那今天得把它吃掉
Lucia: We should eat them today.
Lucia: 不然容易坏
Lucia: Otherwise, they'll spoil.
Katrina:  啊好
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 然后我们再补充一点水果
Lucia: Then we can get some more fruit.
Katrina:  草莓呢也得吃
Katrina: We need to eat the strawberries too.
Lucia: 我都可我都可
Lucia: I can, I can...
Katrina:  是不是还有一盒
Katrina: We still have a box, right?
Alice:草莓有一盒那个要干嘛
Alice: Yeah, there's a box of strawberries. What do you want to do with them?
Alice:做做做
Alice: Make, make, make...
Katrina:  要不要来一箱北冰洋
Katrina: Should we get a case of Beibingyang soda?
Katrina:  北冰洋要配烤肉
Katrina: Beibingyang goes well with BBQ.
Lucia: 可以我都可以
Lucia: Sure, I'm fine with it.
Katrina:  我们小孩吃
Katrina: Our kids can drink it.
Shure:  还小孩呢
Shure: Kids?
Shure:  到法定结
Shure: They're of legal...
Shure:  婚年龄了吧
Shure: Marriage age now, right?
Shure:  我还没到呢
Shure: I'm not even there yet.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure:  我那天还试了一下
Shure: I even tried the other day.
Katrina:  你是去民政局了
Katrina: Did you go to the civil affairs office?
Shure:  不我是民政局预约i am不行
Shure: No, I tried to make an appointment at the civil affairs office. It didn't work.
Katrina:  哎呀我去拿水果去
Katrina: Oh, I'm going to get some fruit.
Lucia: 啊河马
Lucia: Ah, Hema.
Shure:  然后去买调料
Shure: Then let's buy some seasonings.
Shure:  调料在那
Shure: The seasoning is over there.
Shure:  有大瓶的
Shure: There's a big bottle.
Shure:  全是咱们用不了这么多
Shure: We can't use that much.
Shure:  怎么办呢
Shure: What should we do?
Lucia: 烤味呃
Lucia: Barbecue flavor, uh...
Lucia: 烧烤汁吗
Lucia: Barbecue sauce?
Shure:  不是需要料酒
Shure: No, we need cooking wine.
Alice:放料酒吗
Alice: Add cooking wine?
Shure:  不然的话技师会很行
Shure: Otherwise, the chef won't be satisfied.
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onion?
Shure:  也不行得需要料酒
Shure: No, we need cooking wine.
Lucia: 如果说
Lucia: If...
Shure:  九块九六块九的
Shure: 9.9 or 6.9?
Shure:  哎一新币两新币
Shure: Oh, one dollar or two dollars.
Shure:  这太大了这也
Shure: This is too big. It will be wasted.
Shure:  吃不了就浪费了
Shure: If we can't finish it, it'll be wasted.
Lucia: 耗油
Lucia: Oyster sauce.
Shure:  有小的吗
Shure: Is there a smaller one?
Shure:  你好这些有小的吗
Shure: Hi, do you have a smaller one?
Alice:这种的多少钱你看
Alice: How much is this kind? Look.
Lucia: 但那个反而其实要比这个贵嘞
Lucia: But that one is actually more expensive.
Lucia: 但是体感上我们浪费的少了一些
Lucia: But we waste less with it.
Lucia: 或者如能不能用酱油代替蚝油
Lucia: Or can we use soy sauce instead of oyster sauce?
Lucia: 房房间里有酱油吗
Lucia: Is there soy sauce in the room?
Alice:蚝油你要用来腌啥
Alice: What do you need oyster sauce for?
Shure:  也是腌肉
Shure: Also for marinating meat.
Alice:白糖我没有白糖
Alice: I don't have any white sugar.
Shure:  你说白糖还要要一瓶
Shure: You said you need a bottle of white sugar.
Shure:  一定要一瓶百事可乐
Shure: We definitely need a bottle of Pepsi.
Shure:  因为可口没有那么甜
Shure: Because Coke isn't sweet enough.
Shure:  哎那有那有蚝油啊
Shure: Oh, there's oyster sauce over there.
Alice:要更贵
Alice: It's more expensive.
Lucia: 但是它其实更贵
Lucia: But it is actually more expensive.
Shure:  我们是以着不浪费的原则
Shure: We follow the principle of not wasting.
Shure:  还是以更贵的原则
Shure: Or the principle of being more expensive.
Lucia: 嗯看你是指资源还是金钱的浪费了
Lucia: Yeah, it depends on whether you mean wasting resources or money.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  我是指资源过几天
Shure: I mean resources, in a few days...
Alice:我们过几天会有什么饭需要做吗
Alice: Will we have any meals to cook in a few days?
Shure:  不会
Shure: No way.
Alice:不会啊
Alice: No way.
Lucia: 做饭感觉主要只是为了采集一下
Lucia: Cooking mainly feels like just gathering.
Lucia: 人类活动而已
Lucia: It's just human activity.
Shure:  这玩意够用一个月的了都
Shure: This stuff is enough for a month.
Alice:耗油很省的
Alice: It's very economical with the oil.
Shure:  对啊来来这个吧来这个
Shure: Yeah, come on, let's use this.
Shure:  然后别别浪费粮食
Shure: And don't waste food.
Shure:  浪费粮食
Shure: Don't waste food.
Alice:蘸料
Alice: Dipping sauce.
Shure:  这都是腌咸的
Shure: These are all pickled and salty.
Shure:  就不用蘸料了
Shure: So no need for dipping sauce.
Alice:不用摘啊
Alice: No need to dip?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:那孜然呢
Alice: What about cumin?
Shure:  孜然那些调料是要用的
Shure: Cumin and those seasonings are necessary.
Shure:  再找一下这边
Shure: Look around here again.
Alice:六婆直接六婆吧
Alice: Let's just use Liupo directly.
Shure:  六婆是什么
Shure: What is Liupo?
Alice:六婆辣椒面
Alice: Liupo chili powder.
Shure:  我靠没听过这个
Shure: Oh wow, never heard of that.
Alice:六婆这么有名的蘸料
Alice: Liupo is such a famous dipping sauce.
Shure:  真没清过
Shure: Really never heard of it.
Shure:  盐咱们有是吧
Shure: We have salt, right?
Alice:有
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 哈哈哈还行吧
Jake: Hahaha, it's okay.
Shure:  有
Shure: Yes.
Alice:糖也有
Alice: We also have sugar.
Jake: 100新币一只
Jake: 100 SGD each.
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me see.
Lucia: 什么呀
Lucia: What is it?
Lucia: 是是那天那个1,600块钱的帝王蟹吗
Lucia: Is it that 1,600 yuan king crab from that day?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈不是
Jake: Hahaha, no.
Lucia: 还是啥
Lucia: Or what?
Shure:  哎波龙才469啊
Shure: Hey, the Boston lobster is only 469 yuan?
Shure:  换算除5的话不到100新币
Shure: Converted, it's less than 100 SGD.
Shure:  90都不到
Shure: Not even 90.
Jake: 波龙还是波龙不应该这么贵
Jake: Boston lobsters shouldn't be that expensive.
Lucia: 哎我也想说
Lucia: Yeah, I was thinking the same.
Lucia: 其实波龙在国内还挺贵的
Lucia: Actually, lobsters are quite expensive in China.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 波龙在波士顿就十十美元
Jake: In Boston, lobsters are just ten dollars.
Jake: 10美元一只
Jake: Ten dollars each.
Lucia: 哦那比在比在伦敦还便宜
Lucia: Oh, that's even cheaper than in London.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 当时吃了一周就天天的买
Jake: At that time, we ate it for a week, buying it every day.
Jake: 然后吃腻了
Jake: And then we got tired of it.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 听起来很爽的亚子
Lucia: Sounds pretty awesome.
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yeah, it was.
Lucia: 伦敦大概15磅
Lucia: In London, it's around 15 pounds.
Alice:扔这里面呗
Alice: Just throw it in here.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 啊我喜欢这个
Lucia: Ah, I like this.
Alice:山竹
Alice: Mangosteen.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake: 还缺什么呀
Jake: What else do we need?
Jake: 明早让他们做个早饭
Jake: Let's have them make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Jake: 明早你们做个早饭吧
Jake: You guys make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 啊明早会做
Jake: Yeah, make breakfast tomorrow.
Jake: 明天明早做早饭吧
Jake: Tomorrow morning, let's have breakfast.
Tasha:  可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia: 可以做我们刚才是不是买了面包
Lucia: We can do that. Didn't we buy bread earlier?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 还是怎么回事来着
Lucia: Or what was it again?
Jake: 对面包是要烤的啊还没对
Jake: Yeah, the bread needs to be toasted, right?
Alice:面包还没买呢
Alice: We haven't bought the bread yet.
Tasha:  土司片是吗
Tasha: You mean the sliced bread?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina:  买个面包搞点番茄酱就行了
Katrina: Just get some bread and some ketchup.
Tasha:  然后再买点生菜
Tasha: And then buy some lettuce.
Tasha:  直接做个三明治
Tasha: Just make a sandwich.
Alice:刚才有但是不知道够不够
Alice: We had some earlier, but I don't know if it's enough.
Tasha:  但是不知道够不够
Tasha: But I'm not sure if it's enough.
Katrina:  hamburger
Katrina: Hamburger.
Jake: 明天就在
Jake: Tomorrow we'll just...
Jake: 就就在屋里待着了
Jake: Just stay inside.
Katrina:  可以呀
Katrina: Sure
Jake: 跳跳舞什么的
Jake: Dancing or something
Jake: 然后如果快递到了就整一整
Jake: And if the delivery arrives, just sort it out
Katrina:  对明天主要快递会很多
Katrina: Yeah, there will be a lot of deliveries tomorrow
Lucia: 到这个我的快递为什么还没到
Lucia: Why hasn't my delivery arrived yet?
Lucia: 我在京东上买的东西
Lucia: I bought something on JD
Lucia: 应该今天到啊
Lucia: It should arrive today
Jake: 好行行好的
Jake: Okay, okay, good
Jake: 好可以好
Jake: Alright, good
Katrina:  你要回去啊
Katrina: Are you going back?
其他人：我要赶紧回别墅拿东西
Others: I need to hurry back to the villa to get something
Katrina:  打卡吗
Katrina: Clocking out?
其他人：然后再回去
Others: Then I’ll come back
Katrina:  啊那你好折腾
Katrina: Wow, you're so busy
Katrina:  拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye bye
Shure:  哪里有
Shure: Where is it?
Jake: 周日见周日来是吧
Jake: See you Sunday, right?
Shure:  拜拜哦
Shure: Bye bye
其他人：周日周日见
Others: See you Sunday
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye
Shure:  那是咱们是6个人啊
Shure: So there are six of us, right?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What?
Shure:  那没事吃不了
Shure: Then it’s fine, we can’t finish it
Lucia: 有什么要拿的吗
Lucia: Is there anything to take?
Jake: 对可以好
Jake: Yeah, it's fine
Shure:  没事了没事
Shure: No problem, no problem
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye
Katrina:  拜拜
Katrina: Bye
Shure:  哇你还买冰淇淋了
Shure: Wow, you even bought ice cream
Shure:  孜然哥我们还需要孜然
Shure: Cumin guy, we still need cumin
Lucia: 呃在配送途中
Lucia: Uh, it's on the way
Katrina:  这是孜然啊
Katrina: This is cumin?
Shure:  这是孜然粉
Shure: This is cumin powder
Shure:  不是孜然
Shure: Not cumin seeds
Katrina:  孜然和孜然粉有什么区别
Katrina: What's the difference between cumin seeds and cumin powder?
Alice:我们还有白胡椒
Alice: We also have white pepper
Katrina:  孜然和孜然粉有什么区别
Katrina: What's the difference between cumin seeds and cumin powder?
Shure:  粒儿的和粉它其实不太一样
Shure: Seeds and powder are actually quite different
Lucia: 我喜欢这个
Lucia: I like this one
Alice:这是啥辣椒粉吗
Alice: Is this chili powder?
Katrina:  辣椒面
Katrina: Chili flakes.
Katrina:  买面包了吗
Katrina: Did you buy bread?
Katrina:  没有是吧
Katrina: No, right?
Alice:还没买面包呢
Alice: Haven't bought bread yet.
Shure:  行那再买点面面包
Shure: Alright, let's buy some bread then.
Katrina:  买个面包个番茄酱
Katrina: Buy some bread and ketchup.
Shure:  然后剩下的没有了就外卖一下吧
Shure: If we run out of other stuff, let's just order takeout.
Katrina:  OK走吧
Katrina: Okay, let's go.
Katrina:  然后我们最大的花销就是吃
Katrina: Our biggest expense is food.
Lucia: 这里没有
Lucia: Not here.
Lucia: 那天那个帝王蟹耶
Lucia: Remember that king crab the other day?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈建立不了关联
Jake: Hahaha, can't make the connection.
Jake: 关联建立失败
Jake: Connection failed.
Katrina:  哎这是吃饭点
Katrina: Oh, it's lunch time.
Katrina:  人家烘焙区呢
Katrina: Where's the bakery section?
Katrina:  上次来的河马没有这种店哎
Katrina: The Hema we went to last time didn't have this kind of store.
Alice:这应该不是
Alice: This probably isn't it.
Lucia: 尝试一下建立别的关联
Lucia: Try making a different connection.
Lucia: 那天还看到什么了
Lucia: What else did we see that day?
Katrina:  走那边吧
Katrina: Let's go that way.
Alice:啊这个是吗
Alice: Ah, is this it?
Katrina:  走那边绕回去什么
Katrina: Let's go around that way.
Alice:面食之类的不知道好像不是那种
Alice: Pasta and stuff, I don't think it's like that.
Katrina:  哎也可以蒸玉米哈
Katrina: Oh, we can steam corn too.
Katrina:  玉米是不是得往锅里蒸啊
Katrina: Should we steam the corn in a pot?
Katrina:  不能放微波炉吧
Katrina: Can't put it in the microwave, right?
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Alice:但我们有锅
Alice: But we have a pot.
Shure:  有小弟弟啊
Shure: We have a little brother.
Shure:  不对
Shure: No, wait.
Shure:  应该算
Shure: Should count.
Jake: 咋的
Jake: What's up?
Shure:  其实我们还可以弄点什么花蛤啥的
Shure: Actually, we could get some clams or something.
Shure:  烤一下哦
Shure: Grill them.
Shure:  最重要的碳
Shure: Most important is the charcoal.
Shure:  对一会回去的路上咱们先把碳点着
Shure: Yeah, let's light the charcoal on our way back.
Shure:  然后分两
Shure: Then divide it.
Katrina:  有点碳的东西吗
Katrina: Do we have anything to light the charcoal with?
Alice:火枪里面也可以不用
Alice: You don't have to use the gunpowder either.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure:  刚刚那会好像你们你们先往那边走
Shure: Just now it seemed like you guys went that way first.
Alice:你想要酸奶吗
Alice: Do you want some yogurt?
Lucia: 我都可以
Lucia: I'm okay with anything.
Alice:我想找一个无糖的
Alice: I want to find a sugar-free one.
Katrina:  可以搞这种小瓶酸奶放冰箱里
Katrina: We can get these small bottles of yogurt and keep them in the fridge.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  大家想喝就喝
Katrina: Everyone can drink whenever they want.
Lucia: 我是一个都可以的树懒
Lucia: I'm a sloth who is okay with anything.
Lucia: 小瓶那像这种
Lucia: Those small bottles like these.
Lucia: 然后可以分装
Lucia: Then we can portion them out.
Lucia: 我感觉这玩意好像也不便宜
Lucia: I feel like this stuff isn't cheap either.
Tasha:  嗯在逛超市呢咋了
Tasha: Hmm, we're shopping at the supermarket, what's up?
Katrina:  孩子买的小小装的
Katrina: The kids bought these small packs.
Jake: 他那个尝的是这个
Jake: The one he tasted was this one.
Jake: 玩意是什么牌子呀
Jake: What brand is this?
其他人：乐纯
Others: Lechun.
Katrina:  下面这个吗
Katrina: Is it the one below this?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：对拌坚果吃的
Others: Yes, the one to mix with nuts.
Jake: 叫叫啥
Jake: What's it called again?
其他人：0蔗糖的原价卖39块9的
Others: Zero sucrose, originally sold for 39.9 yuan.
Jake: 有牌子吗
Jake: Does it have a brand?
其他人：现在22块9促销的
Others: Now it's on sale for 22.9 yuan.
Jake: 我靠认不得
Jake: Damn, I can't recognize it.
其他人：这一排就便宜16块钱呢
Others: This whole row is just 16 yuan cheaper.
Katrina:  我建议是拿这种小小的
Katrina: I suggest getting these small ones.